Let's go next to our caller from the seven
zero three area code color from seven zero
three.
What's your name?
Where you're calling from?
Yes, it is.
Hello.
Yes.
Um, uh, um, my name's Todd.
I'm from Western Pennsylvania.
Great.
Um, I was actually kinda thinking about things
our two party system and I can't help but
think that, um, it, Oh, manage it.
I've organized my thoughts there.
Todd, it seems like you're basically parenting
there.
Can you hear me at all?
We can hear you just fine.
Yeah, we can hear someone else there too.
Oh, that's my daughter.
So, um, she's small.
Gotcha.
Anyway, so I cannot that, um, particularly
our two D party system, or at least our Congress
could better from actually being completely
nonpartisan and not actually be partied whatsoever.
I can't help but think that if they were,
if somehow we could make Congress complete
like full of independent politicians that
it would actually function better.
And I was wondering what you would think about
that.
In a lot of ways it would, and there are local
elections that are done in this way where
you might have an individual who personally
say considers themselves a Republican and
votes for Republicans nationally, but you
can have like a mayoral election for example,
where there are no parties, uh, declared by
the candidates.
And so in order to figure out who to vote
for it, you actually have to look and see
what are people's policy platforms, what are
people's positions on policies.
And it is very appealing to people like me.
It sounds like to people like you because
we see the party label as more of a problem
than a benefit and sort of sorting candidates
into groups where we would much prefer people
rather than having to act out of allegiance
to party, act out of understanding the policy
positions of an individual.
So I love the idea.
The problem is the following.
A lot of people, uh, are not going to actually
do the work of figuring out what are the policy
positions of individuals.
And you will open up to a whole new type of
attack ad and campaign ad which can say even
crazier things about the positions of a candidate.
And without any sorting method whatsoever,
you may even end up with a less informed electorate.
If you can imagine that.
Like it's bad enough when people show up and
say, I'm just going to vote for every Democrat.
I'm just going to vote for every Republican
with without regard for what it is that they
stand for.
But in our low information environment to
some degree, it provides at least an initial
sorting method that maybe is useful.
So it's, it's a bad in all ways.
I love the idea.
I think at the national level it could have
unintended consequences that we don't like,
but I'm glad you're thinking about it because
D the two party do.
Opoly is not working for a whole bunch of
different reasons.
Oh thanks.
I can't help but look at the like other like
countries and the fact that they have multipolarity
systems and they're not really that much better
than us though.
Sure.
[inaudible] in and of itself, a multi-party
system is, is not always better in all cases,
but I think we should be asking all of these
questions.
I really appreciate the call.
I'm going to let you go and hope to hear from
you again.
Of course.